hello and welcome back to the shakey
Simonson so today we will be addressing
the question what are the antagonistic
hallmarks of aging so for the past few
videos now I've been talking about the
different hallmarks of aging and things
different hallmarks have been
characterized by this for a few people
into three different categories and so
firstly you have the primary causes of
damage secondly you've got the
antagonistic hallmarks which we'll look
at in this video and lastly are the
integrator for Marx that we'll talk
about in the next video so yeah in this
video we'll look at the antagonistic
hallmarks but what does antagonistic
call mark to even mean so in the context
of aging whilst the primary causes are
the primary causes of damage the
antagonistic call marks are responding
to the damage and whilst the primary
causes of damage are bad the
antagonistic or marks can be positive or
negative depending on the context or how
intense the response is so these
hallmarks are that protects the organism
from damaging situations however when
their response is too intense that's
when it can promote aging
so first up on our list is nutrient
signaling dysregulation so nutrient
signaling is pretty much essential for a
cell / organism to live it's when
neutral signaling is too high or
deregulated that it can promotes the
aging phenotype I'm so much
understanding for the involvement of the
nutrient signaling pathways in aging
have come to light from genetic
mutations in genes and both in these
pathways that when mutated either
altered the lifespan or the health span
of the organism so what are these
pathways so I'll give you a simplified
overview so icky nutrient signaling
pathway is the insulin or the igf-1 h1
signaling pathway and so the aim of this
pathway is to activate processes in the
cell that will stimulate growth so as
you can see that I've drawn out care
the insulin or igf-1 will bind with a
receptor at the membrane of the cell and
this triggers an internal response that
activates a KT and so a QT is a kinase
and this phosphorylates a protein called
foxy and foxy is a transcription factor
that will activate genes involved in
stress resistance not growth and say
when it gets phosphorylated by a KT it
can no longer get into the nucleus where
it's needed to act as a transcription
factor therefore growth pathways are
activated
instead of otology or the stress
resistance pathways same to knock a
genetic mutations that strongly effects
an aging are seen an IG F 1 receptor
also known as DAF 2 in C elegans and
foxy also known as daf-16 in C elegans
and now remember that C elegans are
basically once and so daf-2 when it's
mutated prolongs life span whilst when -
16 is mutated it reduces lifespan and
hence it promotes aging so the key thing
to get from this diagram is that when
you increase the signaling response
you're going to inhibit foxy and this is
going to increase the rate of aging and
so part of this is a reduced rate of
poor topper G so Auto for G is the
cellular recycling process effectively
itself digestion of damaged organelles
and proteins that are inside the cell
and this system acts to protect cellular
integrity and function therefore if you
reduce the brain to 400 G it can
accelerate the aging process so to kind
of summarize where we've got to so far
the role of the antagonistic or Mark's
so in this case neutral in signaling
this regulation it acts to accelerate
the primary causes of aging as you can
see here all right so next up is
mitochondrial dysregulation so to
understand the involvement of
mitochondrial dysregulation and the
aging process first thing we need to ask
the question as to well what do the
mitochondria even
so the mitochondria are organelles in
the cell that carry out oxidative
phosphorylation and this is a process
that is used to make ATP / the energy
source for the cell and so there are
kind of three different categories of
how this regulation of the mitochondria
could contribute to aging the first of
these is the free radical theory of
aging which is related to the production
of reactive oxygen species the second is
the accumulation of DNA mutations
specifically in the mitochondrial DNA
and lastly it's the bioenergetic decline
so the fact that over time the
mitochondria can make less ATP and
therefore this less energy for the cell
and therefore there's a reduction and
function can result in the aging process
but what is the evidence for all this so
as with the other antagonistic hallmarks
they are thought to be beneficial at
homeostatic levels in my cell but when
they have too high in intensity they can
be damaging for the cell so for example
with the reactive oxidant species there
have been evidence in support of the
presence of grant of oxygen species
promoting aging but also the reverse
that we needed to prevent aging and
that's because there is evidence that
the reactive oxygen species are
signaling stress and they actually
activate the survival responses but the
problem is when you have too much of the
oxidative species it can actually cause
more damage and more damage can actually
advance the aging process so for example
there is evidence that increased
reactive oxygen species may actually
prolong lifespan in yeast and worms so
bottom line the situation is a little
bit complex but so next up is the
accumulation of mutations in a
mitochondrial DNA so I gave it a sample
in a previous video whereby a mutated
DNA polymerase resulted in increased
accumulation of mutations and this
reduced the lifespan of the mice so in
addition to the accumulation of
mutations defective bioenergetics in the
mitochondria can also occur over time
because of oxidation of the
mitochondrial proteins that reduce their
function
and also into stabilization of the
respiratory chain which is what
generates the ATP because when it gets
to stabilized it can increase the
production of reactive oxygen species so
these three different categories like
highly ample out but the key thing is
that mitochondrial dysregulation does
seems to be involved with the aging
process so the last antagonistic
hallmark is cellular senescence so
cellular senescence is defined as being
a stable cell cycle arrest of the cell
whereby it no longer divides and in
addition to this cell cycle arrest it is
coupled with any security phenotype
referred to as the specimens associated
secretory phenotype or the Sask
which is much easier to say so the first
characterization of senescence was
replicative senescence and that was
subscribed by hayflick and so what he
noticed was that over time after several
cell divisions the human fibroblast
stopped growing and the explanation for
this loss of cell division was due to
telomere attrition which as explained
before telomeres are kind of like the
shoe caps on chromosomes and so when
they shorter and you lose the integrity
of the chromosomes so the kind of
protective thing for a cell to do right
is to stop fighting and to prevent the
accumulation of even more damage in the
DNA which can result in aging so this is
the beneficial side of T's Nessen but
senescence doesn't only occur through
replicative senescence it can also occur
due to damaged cumulation in other areas
of the DNA
alternatively the repression of the ink
for off locus which is a locus that
includes genes that promote cell cycle
arrest could also promote senescence but
there are actually many different ways
that you can cause senescence for cell
and senescence also has many outputs
that can vary depending on the cellular
context so how does senescence
cause aging so we already know that
telomere attrition increases during
aging but both damaged elsewhere and D
repression of the ink for a flickers
every processes that happen
throughout lifespan but still in terms
of how senescence actually promotes the
aging process what is it that's critical
about it and so the key feature and
while is part of the key feature is the
secretion of these molecules Genesis ASP
so what low levels the SAS can actually
be considered beneficial because it
brings in and recruits the immune system
that can bring those cells to sites of
damage in the body and this can help to
repair the types of damage however at
high levels the SAS can have deleterious
effects for the cell and the surrounding
tissue for example it can increase the
inflammation and that tissue and this
can reduce tissue function and also if
some essence occurs in stem cells which
are needed for repair it can also affect
the regeneration of the tissue which are
all pro aging factors so yeah as I've
said before those are a few paper is
really good if you want more detail but
hopefully this videos giving you an
overview as to the antagonistic
hallmarks in the hallmarks of aging